هنا في هذا المختبر في دنفر كولورادو ،
جلب المهندسون
عمليات المسح ثنائية الأبعاد لـ Jaden Ananias إلى الحياة ثلاثية الأبعاد
بشكل فعال ، مما منح الجراحين
نموذجًا دقيقًا للتدرب عليه قبل
الدخول إلى غرفة العمليات.
الكثير مما نقوم به هنا هو رعاية شخصية
دقيقة للرعاية الصحية ، ومع ذلك
يأتي أساسًا في تشريح المريض ، لذلك
من أجل أن تكون شخصيًا ، عليك أن
تبدأ بصور تشريح المريض
التي تأتي إلينا عادةً
في شكل التصوير المقطعي المحوسب.  مسح ضوئي في السيد حتى في بعض
الحالات ، يقوم فريق كاتي بالموجات فوق الصوتية
بتحويل التصوير التقليدي ثنائي
الأبعاد إلى نماذج ثلاثية الأبعاد واقعية معقدة الآن الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
ليست جديدة في المجال الطبي لجادن
أنانياس ماكدونالد الملتصقة في الرأس
ومشاركة ما يصل إلى بوصتين من
أنسجة المخ
يحتاج الجراحون إلى صور مفصلة بشكل لا يصدق
، حيث يتيح المظهر الافتراضي
للجراحين ممارسة نهجهم ، ما هي
التخفيضات التي يجب إجراؤها عند إجرائها  إن
رفاهية البدء من
جديد
إذا احتاجوا إلى ذلك يوفر مستوى من
الراحة والطمأنينة
التي شاهدها الجراحون قبل أن
يدخلوا غرفة العمليات
صباحًا عيد الميلاد
.
هو اليوم الذي كانت ماكدونالدز
تنتظره في العام الماضي ، أريد أن
أعطيك فكرة بسيطة
عما يحدث هنا من أجل القيام
بهذه العملية ، فعليهم
نقل Jaden Anaya باستمرار ، لذلك هذا هو الموقف
الذي هم عليه  في البداية وانقلبوا بشكل
أساسي هكذا ثم
هكذا الآن سوف يركزون على
هذا الجزء من العظم وفقط جزء
من الدماغ أبلغ مايك جيليش أن
العملية استغرقت ما مجموعه 27 ساعة
جهدًا بطوليًا حقًا من قبل الطبيب بأكمله
الفريق والأولاد الصغار ولكن ليس
بدون صعوبة
على الرغم من التصور التفصيلي
لأدمغتهم تم دمجها حتى أكثر مما
كان يعتقد في الأصل وفي وقت ما
فكر الجراحون في التوقف
طوال ذلك
كاتي  كان e Weimer من أنظمة ثلاثية الأبعاد في
غرفة العمليات لمحاولة مساعدة
الجراحين تم فصل Jaden و
iist بنجاح ، إنها الخطوة الأولى
ولكنها خطوة كبيرة في الطريق الطويل
للشفاء